Pewds: Welcome to my kingdom, Marzia!
M: Thank you!
P: These are my humble servants!
M: I love them!
P: So this is Danny! Uhh... This is Danny
P: Today we're gonna Switch it up!
M: With The Switch!
P: Yes...
P: We never played this before!
P: But it looks pretty fun!
P: Quick Draw. M: I haven't looked at anything, so.
P: Okay!
P: So it's the tutorial!
P: He's holding it in his hand. M: Wait, he's pressing something P: Nah he's just holding his finger on it
P: The finger is out!
GAME: Lower your guns with the muzzle facing the ground
P: You gon' die girl, you ready to die? M: I can't hear!
GAME: Ready.. steady.. P: Don't kill me please
P: I love you Marzia, please, don't do this why did you.. why did you do this?
GAME: FIRE!
M: Did I win?
M: I hope I won
P: You're dead! Go down! Yeah!
M: This time, I'm going to kill you
P: What are you doing in this...
P: It's just so you won't hit my face
P: You gon' die girl!
P: This is what you get for not walking the pugs M: Yeah
M: Well you walk them... kind of. P: On the balcony
M: What's happening?
Pewds: I dont know, it's- oh we haven't started!
M: What's happening? P: I don't know, it's-
GAME: FIRE!
M: I shot you in the face!
P: Ah! Ah! How could you do this? M: I won!
P: How? Whatever, it's 1:1 so... calm down.
Video: "You gotta ask yourself a question.
"Do I feel lucky?"
P: You better than me? M: Yeah.
GAME: Lower your guns. Face each other.
Video: "Well do ya, punk?"
P: Come on! GAME: FIRE! P: I definitely got that one.
M: I felt like I had a booger in my nostril
P: You dead! What did you say?
P: Samurai. You want to do the samurai? Samurai.
P: What? So one has the sword... the other-
P: I have to catch the sword? WHAT?
P: That's gonna hurt that's definitely gonna hurt
M: So how do you do it?
GAME: Ready..... Start!
P: So what do you do to catch it?
M: And then I have to get- oh P: Oh my god
GAME: Game
P: Alright who's gonna start, who's gonna start?
GAME: Left swings first. P: No!
P: Alright M: So I just like, do it- P: You just swing it
GAME: Start!
M: Can I go? P: Why would you hurt me!?
M: It's not going
P: Please Marzia, don't hurt me! Please! GAME: Start!
P: NO- YEAH!
P: What? That's- How. How. How.
M: I need to see it! P: That's so weird!
M: How am I supposed to know? P: You just have to listen
P: How do I win? I'm too good!
P: It's the Swedish blood, we're so good at table tennis
M: No- what!? I'm better than you at table tennis!
P: Why am I winning then? Huh, why am I win- oh!
The Dannys are cheering for me now! Wow!
Danny: oh my gah pewdiepie!
(sub alert)
AUDIO: "Your soul is mine" "NO!"
M: What, too soon- WHAT? We're so close- If this was real life-
P: You got ZERO TALENT! M: If this was real life, I would have to-
P: Well is it- GODDAMN IT WHAT ARE YOU DOING
P: I can't lose!
AUDIO: "The fuck you lookin' at old man"
M: What do we do?
GAME: ??? and feel it vibrate! Face each other!
GAME: On your marks! Get set! False start!
P: Good job. M: What?
M: Oh, run in place!
M: Is it working? P: I don't want to exercise!
P: Who won?
GAME: No result!
M: You're not even running!
M: I got it! P: No I got it!
M: I think we were there for- P: Look how-
P: Oh, that's beautiful. Yes! Yes!
P: Got em! Got em! Danny Devito's goin' crazy!
GAME: Be mindful of your surroundings and stand far enough
apart so you don't bump into it- M: No way!
M: We don't have enough- P: We're gonna die, we're gonna-
P: Just do this, just do this, don't fully engage the attack
??? idk what this is
P: No, we're not pussies, alright. We don't fight for re-
GAME: Now face each other and get ready, try and punch fast and
at your opponent. FIGHT!
*generic fighting terms*
M: I don't know what- hdhhdhd P: What is happening?
rip in peace
P: What did I say? I said don't hit me.
GAME: Rapid fire!
GAME: In a real match, here's how it would have looked!
M: I destroyed you! P: Stop hitting me!
M: What about all of my punches!
M: Did they not see my punches? What is this GAME? Did they not see these punches?
P: Yeah you should talk to Nintendo about that
M: Like do you see these MUSCLES? P: Oh my godddd
GAME: Look at your hands as you milk
P: Squeeze thoroughly GAME: Focus on your hands as you milk from top to bottom!
P: Yeah, I'm trying, shut up game! I'm squeeing like-
GAME: Don't forget to ?????
P: These nipples must be so stretched. Are they nipples? They are nipples.
*marzia ignores felix's nipple confusion*
P: What happened? M: A big one!
P: How did you get-
P: How did you get so much milk out?
P: You ready to shave, girl? M: Yes!
P: You ready to shave!? This is the ultimate challenge!
GAME: Shaving contest! The first player to shave off their entire beard wins!
P: Yeah we got that.
M: Wait wait wait! P: What is happening here?
P: Oh my god, it's so inaccurate M: Yeah, it's not going-
M: Wait what!? Nonononono!
(what is anyone saying i have no idea)
(subs brought 2 u by @listerinejjong buy base on itunes)
P: What are you doing- that's not how you shave!
P: You're not applying makeup Marzia, it needs a little bit more time.
M: Oh, I found a bit up there!
M: What? P: We ran out of time
P: HOW. HOW. HOW. HOW.
P: HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE
P: What the hell. M: Would you look at- P: What the hell.
GAME: Dance!
GAME: Stop! M: I'll kick you!
P: YOU KICKED MY CONTROLLER WHAT ARE YOU DOING
GAME: Dance!
GAME: Stop!
GAME: That's it! P: Thank god, I thought I was gonna get a heart attack.
GAME: Let's hear it for this dance machine!
M: But my energy though- oh wait. P: But MY energy though.
P: Good job, Marzia. You did great today. Thank you for losing.
P: You lost, how does it feel, what are you gonna say to everyone?
M: How can you tell that I lost?
P: You lost bec- M: I won so many of some other challenges.
P: Well, we'll leave it to the comments M: Yeah, who won?
M: Well, thank you for watching hhddggh *pewds impression* Hhhh brofist
P: Was that me? You tryna make fun of me? M: No
P: Thank you guys for watching, leave a like if you enjoyed, and as always, brofist hdhhdghd